Bây giờ, em Andi Rano đã đoạnThuyên truyền của anh có lúc when we are in a very competitive market.
Đ tätä đã bị lãi l不多.
Hãy lại bây giờ, lai lưu đỡi and có điên giữ Què?
Hãy lấy khi Hộng Tại Nguồn, và con suyên lâu,
hãy бởi vì thật tựa mình làm cái arkadaşlar.
Djection đã giữ được.
Hãy có đến giữ đoạn thật đoạn dizer được hắn.
Hãy bị giữ hắn lỡi, hãy có đếnShit了.
Hãy bởi vì cô, nếu mà thật thật thật.
đài Conần Dí W pouvoir然后 hãy tính.
Mấy một mưa quốc một quốc to mưa khi một đoạn braucht,
Nếu tên bình hút đoạn,
không thử những tên hút đoạn,
không thử tên hút đoạn,
không thử tên hút đoạn.
Nếu bố lúc,
vụ thì ra khóng và đoạn,
không thử tên hút đoạn,
cho a trời bởi giống như b Ét quản áo, và lỗi v bisher đến,
và b expectations quà giới bắt đầu,
trong cái trời bắt đầu sống của các nè.
Thế rất lộn,
chất ciam,
Hoàng đường bộng bộng bộng bộng bộng bộng bộng bộng bộng,
chất chất chất cây,
chất chất chất chất chất chất chất chất chất chất chất chất chất chất.
And Hanh say the customer experience and the quality of your pride.
And to be specific about Phu Clon,
Of course, those three are our big considerations, right?
Um, um,
since I joined the company,
my biggest focus has been on those trời.
with regards to customer satisfaction,
we're working very diligently with learning and development
ensued when resources to ensure that all of our team members have the opportunity
to be trained,
properly from the day they are hired.
2. Quà lỡi T. Quà lỡi T.
I have to tell you the level of quality in Phu Clong is of the highest.
Our quality control team is one of the largest I have worked on any FMB company.
I promise. But what we are working with is a research and development.
So we can bring new attractive and highly quality level drinks to this consumer.
And finally, definitely continue to develop the brand.
So in finally, a story development is so so important, definitely.
It is our aim to continue to grow the brand and be available for every Vietnamese.
So we have the benefit of having the terrain to do it.
Meaning we have T growing regions very close to almost every city.
Right? There is enormous amount of T farms in the north.
North of Hanoi, West of Hanoi. There is a large amount of T growers in the center.
And there is a significant amount of T growers very close to what you need.
Right? As close as Bau L'oc.
So the terrain is so available.
And that means that our teams have the accessibility to truly see how T growth.
How T is blocked. How T is roasted. Right?
How to is T tasted from the con sairs to see the strength for them to qualify how good this season is.
So I think having those possibilities plays a huge role in the lingo that our team members can use.
In the photos that we have, in that picture that they bring back to their stores. Right?
They saw this lady picking the first leaf to get the white tea. Right? Which is only the first leaf.
So she goes at each of the bushes to pick only one leaf. Amazing.
So imagine that they can convey that in such a proud manner because they've been there, they met a lady, they talked to her.
And they're one in the same. They are con suyệt con suyệt or Vietnamese tea.
In Vietnam, ready to bring that wonderful tea to the rest of Vietnamese con suyệt.